what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with marvel dark ages by tom
taylor yes we are and uh yeah man this
is
i have no idea what i'm going to title
this video yet
i have no idea what's going on what i'm
going to call it but uh yeah so how many
youtubers do you guys know who are gonna
upload two videos on their own birthday
who are gonna work on their own birthday
so in the basically the aftermath of the
first video that we did where in effect
a constant emp has been essentially
blanketing the world and everything's
gone dark what this does is it leads to
a war between you could kind of call it
the heroes and the villains but not
necessarily so the way that spider-man
narrates this because again peter
parker's the one giving us this
monologue he says after our world went
dark people were scared and grieving and
their fear turned into anger there were
wars fought over borders resources
ideologies it was chaos between the
initial earthquakes the loss of power
and the wars billions of lives were lost
one of the best things about this the
way that tom taylor does it and he does
this routinely whenever it comes to
stories that he's writing that deal with
like massive wars and things like that
it doesn't really fall down these
ideologies of like heroes versus
villains right good guys versus versus
bad guys it really just kind of falls
down into the line of like desperation
is really what it is because one of the
things to know this is one of the cool
things about tom taylor that i like a
lot of heroes are heroes because the
circumstance simply allows it but in
times of desperation people will believe
what they want to believe and so what
happens when a hero loses everything
they care about when they lose their
family or they lose their friends or
something like that it's very easy to
lose that ideology of like i am saving a
world especially when you look around
and you see a world that doesn't look
like it wants to be saved or a world
that simply won't save itself it's very
easy to walk away from that philosophy
the truth about this is that every
single superhero aside from just these
cosmic entities or whatever they're
humans first and they're super powered
being second which means emotions wants
needs desires all those things begin to
take precedence and that's why like
resource wars ideological wars border
skirmishes all these things begin to
take place because those individuals who
always saw themselves maintaining this
kind of smaller place in the world now
see the opportunity to expand out but
there was a really cool story that i
read years and years and years ago and
it's it doesn't have anything to do with
comics but it was talking about what
would happen with a collapse of society
and what you would end up seeing are
basically the rise of like petty
warlords and like strong men they would
basically create these kind of small
communities and people would rally under
them for some measure of protection and
that seems to be a lot of what you're
seeing here the difference is that where
this war could have initially led to the
falls really to the ruin of all what you
end up getting is those who are truly
altruistic right those individuals out
there who fight as superheroes because
it's truly the right thing to do
actually step forward because spider-man
says but then cutting through all that
fear rage and chaos came a voice of calm
and a message started to spread it
doesn't have to be like this and this is
one of the really cool things that you
don't normally get to see that you have
all these heroes who come forward and
they're like we can be better than this
right we can be better than like
fighting border skirmishes and likely
involving massive you know weapons of
mass destruction and things like that
because billions of lives being lost in
a period of time that's a pretty huge
thing and so you have like like laura
kinney x23 wolverine if you want to call
her that black panther shang chi
deadpool
in his own unique way deadpool's
actually amazing in this story uh but
you get these people who basically step
forward right kamala khan but and then
of course you end up getting captain
america telling this guy like it doesn't
have to be this way and that's when you
have the telepaths who really chime in
and say like we can be better than this
and it's a really really cool concept
because now there is no such thing as
hero versus villain anymore or at least
that's the idea they're putting forward
it's simply just survivors and that
makes sense that's usually what happens
right it's not even an enemy of my enemy
it's my friend it's i'm trying to
survive you're trying to survive let's
survive together because if we just keep
going to war we're all going to
eventually die and so what's taken place
in the aftermath of all this right the
seven years that have followed since
really i guess really these wars taking
place and things like that this kind of
seven year period since the emp was
initially started is we're told that
with a smaller population without
electricity industrialization and mass
production the world started coming back
from the brink of like climate
destruction people fled the most
inhospitable places and came to thriving
centers what was left of humanity
sheltered from the darkness together
these super cities were each linked by a
powerful telepath so while the world was
divided by distance it was also
connected by people who opened their
minds and hid nothing from each other
all with a common goal now this is a
wildly utopian and super progressive and
ideological concept would something like
this ever truly come into pass i don't
know probably hundreds if not maybe a
couple thousand years from now assuming
we as humanity don't obliterate
ourselves off the face of the planet
global war or something like that but
it's cool to see all these heroes and
really just just people with powers in
general humanity as a whole casting
aside the notions of like small time
differing factors and in turn uniting
under a single common ideology because
when you look at it for what it is right
like borders between countries is kind
of dumb
what separates a person in mexico from a
person in america nothing except a
border right like we all are human
beings like we all have these these
personal mindsets when we want to like
thrive and we want to succeed and we
want to experience a better life
cultural differences sure but there's
really no reason why those things can't
like co-exist at the same time and so
what you end up getting here is
basically this idea that wakanda is
essentially the leader of the world
we'll call it that wakanda conquered the
world
but wakanda is literally the capital
city of earth it's not the capital city
of like new york or like the united
states like new wakanda or something
like that although the name new wakanda
does sound awesome instead it's
basically just a place this is the
capital place where seemingly the most
important people reside and do the most
important work now one of the things
that they've been focusing on here and
they've been trying to achieve is trying
to find a way to at the very least bring
some measure of technology back they
can't necessarily reactivate or shut
down that emp because if they do the
unmaker will show up but in the end what
pewter tells us is that the center of
our new world earth's capital was
wakanda a council of great theorists
innovated every day in the city some of
the best minds linked together by jean
grey lunella lafayette shuri tony stark
valeria richards t'challa nadia van dyne
amadeus cho and victor von doom joined
the greatest of the non-powered thinkers
which is kind of incorrect for doctor
doom although he doesn't inherently have
power he's like he's like doctor strange
basically they reimagined what the world
could be they dreamed up lighting and
refrigeration whole new systems of food
production and preservation shelter and
governance together they created a
post-apocalyptic utopia but how did we
protect our utopia we built webs now
this is a genius concept right it's a
genius idea and it really is kind of
like spider-man and really the spider
community living up to really their
namesakes but as you guys know whenever
whenever when it comes to spiders they
have webbing right they have like
spiders wets and whenever something
trips the spider's web that's when it
tells a spider there is a thing there
which is usually there for me to eat to
consume right something along those
lines but having that set up here where
webbing is all over the place and
there's no real way for anybody to
access uh the really get within range of
any of these cities without basically
accessing webbing because if they were
to fly over it somebody would notice
right if they were to go underground
there's likely sensors and things like
that that they could use to detect it
and so having webbing set up people are
like okay something's going on at that
point one of the web snaps and that's
when they realize something's here right
like literally it rings about and in
doing so while it is a primitive form of
technology it's exceedingly effective
and so the funny thing about this is
that there's a conversation between
foggy nelson and daredevil where it's
like okay like where was this and
daredevil was like well it's over there
you know and so he's like should we send
up a flare and foggy's like no need
right like uh wolverine will basically
know by now laura kinney has immediately
picked up on the fact that somebody's
there and using her scent is able to
essentially track them down not only
that what they've got here and this is
one of the cool things what they've got
here is elsa bloodstone blade gabby who
is the the clone of laura kinney and
then laura kinney herself this is
basically the team you have when you're
facing off against like supernatural
threats especially elsa bloodstone she's
really really cool and i'm really hoping
they make a series about her at some
point but the reason why this team
exists together is because in the
absence of humanity just largely
existing in unprotected cities and with
most of humanity taking refuge in
protected cities what it does is it
leaves a landscape open for other
predators to make their way out there in
an effort to track and find humanity
specifically an alliance seems to have
been struck between werewolves and
vampires and this is amazing because you
literally have like all these guys
teaming up now whether or not this this
werewolf is jack russell right werewolf
by night i don't know if it is and i
don't think it is uh we're not really
told either way they're dealt with
pretty quickly but one of the vampires
actually manages to make their way into
the laboratory of of tony stark
alongside pepper hutts and you have this
voice kind of out of nowhere that's like
tony stark like i expected better of you
you'd think a brilliant inventor would
invent a door
only for us to find out it's captain
america and it's cool to see the steve
rogers has made it through all this
stuff you'd kind of expect him to right
but it's cool to see that he did but one
of the things that goes on and he
basically talks about how he has largely
been operating in europe at this point
because in all honesty like they they
were kind of kind of afraid that like
something had happened to him because
he'd been gone for so long that iron man
has done really cool stuff like he's
mastered alchemy the ability to turn
like metal into gold which is like
really cool specifically lead really
turned led into gold which is a pretty
awesome concept but at the end of the
day the the whole idea of captain
america is he says like he's been in
europe this whole time and that it's
still being ruled by an iron fist and he
says they need help tony like can we
take a walk we need your ability to step
in and to basically deal with this now
one of the cool things about this is the
relationship between tony stark and
captain america because on the surface
and those of you guys who've been
reading mobile comics for a long time
know that the relationship between tony
stark and captain america was always
pretty strong until you got to civil war
and then in the aftermath of civil war
the relationship between the two was
tenuous at best now it's not to say
things were perfect right it was not
harmonious over the years in marvel
comics tony stark and iron man had
always kind of budded heads in one way
or another but civil war was kind of the
the you know crossing the line right it
was like we can't like this this is
something that we can't necessarily
reconcile and even in the aftermath of
civil war and the launch and going into
like the future of new avengers and
things like that there was a lot of it
was very very tense the way that it was
written by like bendis and those guys it
was a struggle
right trying to find a way to have these
two work together because they're so
significant in the superhero community
but also put some of their issues aside
was always a very difficult thing and it
was one of those things that because of
the way that marvel had written these
characters whether they were on the same
team or they were somehow teaming up in
their own individual books it was always
done in such a way to where you knew
lingering in the background was the
massive civil war event that was caused
either by tony stark or by captain
america depending on what side you were
on but the the reality here is that you
have this whole thing where captain
america is like we need you to basically
step in and to to in effect use your
mind in order to help europe basically
liberate itself right to become free of
its dictator that's running the whole
show only you can really pull this off
tony stark and so in the end when tony's
like okay like where are we going like
like what's going on ultimately captain
america says there's something i need to
show you and when he basically pulls
back the the shrubbery and whatnot and
shows tony stark what it is that he
wanted to show him it's apocalypse and
his horsemen and it's like hello iron
man and literally tony stark goes to
like try to escape try to offer a
distraction but in the at the end of the
day he's snatched up by dracula and
that's the crazy thing because now you
literally have
[Laughter]
you have apocalypse's four horsemen
which is composed of some pretty capable
guys dracula being one of them which is
kind of ironic because in marvel comics
uh apocalypse fought dracula at one
point in time like they're enemies right
they're enemies but at the end of the
day again there's no real enemies versus
enemies anymore now it's just people
trying to survive not only that is like
iron man is trying to like fight off and
he tells captain america you have to get
dracula off of me the response of
captain america is no and then he knocks
tony stark unconscious and so in essence
it looks like steve rogers has betrayed
uh tony stark only for us to find out
it's not steve rogers it's mystique
pretending to be steve rogers and that
was amazing like i never saw that coming
i had no idea that was the case i really
thought it was captain america who had
turned against tony stark and my thought
was what could have possibly happened
that captain america would betray
righteousness and go against tony stark
like like literally ally himself with
apocalypse when would that ever happen
but at the end of the day of course
apocalypse with tony stark knocked
unconscious they snatch him up and they
teleport away and they bring tony stark
to europe now the funny thing about this
is that there's a discussion that
happens between the two and this is one
of the reasons why i love apocalypse so
much right they have they have this kind
of discussion where tony stark has woken
up by apocalypse which one it's just
cool to see iron man interacting with
apocalypse because you never really see
that happen it's one of the things that
i love when it comes to like these crazy
kind of out there what if stories where
like you never really see uh you see
characters basically cross paths and
interact where they usually never do and
seeing tony stark talking with
apocalypse is just cool man it's just
cool but ultimately like apocalypse is
like you need to see things on my you
know from my perspective like you need
to basically be on my side here uh in
the end like i only thought mutants were
the ones worth saving but it turns out
you caught my attention because of your
intelligence you know like you shall
work for me
and the response of tony stark is like
no like i'm not gonna work for a guy who
makes slaves build statues out of him
and then apocalypse makes this amazing
counter argument he says and were your
iron man suits not partly shining
tributes to yourself were the medals not
mined by slaves in other lands you
understand as i do stark evolution uses
and kills the inferior and undeserving
there can be no progress with our world
rendered stagnant it is time to evolve
again and that's when you end up finding
out that people working for apocalypse
are some bigger people riri williams
right the girl who basically reverse
engineered iron man's own technology and
created her own iron man suit reed
richards of the fantastic four these
guys are allied with apocalypse not only
that apocalypse has basically found a
way to start creating electricity again
he basically created what's called a
faraday cage which is immune to the
constant emp but every single cage that
iron man has tried to build has
ultimately failed that he's used
adamantium vibranium the electromagnetic
pulse in the earth is simply just too
strong and he says you need you know
some kind of force that's equally as
strong to repel it and that's when iron
man realizes at the center of this
faraday cage emitting this magnetic
pulse or basically countering the
electromagnetic pulse is magneto then in
essence apocalypse got his hands on
magneto and now he's forcing him to
operate inside this cage the other thing
here is we end up learning all these
people who are working for apocalypse
are not doing so willingly that while
tony stark is slightly distracted he
realizes the purple man is there and
that's what apocalypse says take his
mind and the purple man does that seizes
control of of tony stark and that's
basically what's happened with everybody
and so as it ends or at least as this
issue ends apocalypse has as you guys
know apocalypse makes like the best
model has the best statements he
literally says i touched the mind of a
being more powerful than a god then the
earth stopped and the being slept i want
that power you're going to help me wake
the unmaker tony stark an apocalypse
simply just walks away with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end i love dark ages it's just
ridiculously good this is a ridiculously
good story like i said i blew through
this thing in an hour and a half but
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace